a Race Against Time in this Hospital in
sehwan a village in southern Pakistan
a growing number of children suffering
from malaria and other contagious
diseases are being rushed to hospitals
the country is trying to overcome the
aftermath of its worst floods in recent
memory
I wish and I pray to Allah that the
people this place where floods get back
to their homes before the winter they
will be exposed to respiratory illness
and pneumonia in Winter living in tents
most of these patients are from areas
that were submerged when unprecedented
Monsoon rains fell in the last two
months most of these patients are from
areas that were submerged when
unprecedented Monsoon rains fell in
August and September doctor said she had
malaria this is our Fortnight here and
I'm worried there's nothing to eat here
but Allah has been very kind to give us
everything the floods displaced more
than 30 million people
lost her house along with her husband
and two children getting food and
shelter is a daily struggle
a pregnant woman and a and it's hard for
me to get some food for myself and my
kids I go barefooted to get some food
where I have to wait for hours and hours
which is putting my life and that off my
baby at risk there isn't any help from
anyone we're dying of starvation and
diseases one third of the country has
been affected by the flooding the
authorities are desperate for
international Aid the devastation has
made people more concerned about threats
from climate change and in a nation that
suffers from long cycles of drought and
high temperatures many fear the worse
may be yet to come